hey guys and welcome to gamespot of
Thrones Dave where are we this week we
are in sunny la well Sonny is inside to
see all the wonderful games for e3 and
despite with being so busy seeing the
games doesn't mean we haven't got enough
time for Game of Thrones and especially
when so much happens like they did in
last night's episode so wait are we
talking about season 6 episode 8 no one
you haven't seen it turn away now so in
the Riverlands we accurately predicted
the Hound is on somewhat of a rampage oh
yeah he thought he had his little
peaceful time well then he had the
peaceful time then all his friends died
and then he finds the Brotherhood's
brigands and wants to ask them some
questions oh my god I can't believe you
just did that I'm so glad that you did
the Brotherhood without banners so we're
under the impression that they were
under the control of Lady Stoneheart but
no it's our favorite um Jane Espenson is
making it back beric Dondarrion and
Thoris of Maya they're still around the
barracks still in charge of the
Brotherhood without banners and they
basically convinced the Hound that you
know you ain't all so bad you're not so
bad you should join us because basically
all the stuff you've done in the past
seriously the stuff that you can do in
the future can totally redeem yourself
but a couple of fan theories I think
I've been completely debunked in this
episode I'm not sure if we're gonna see
Lady Stoneheart know like that the
theory was that she replaces barrington
therrien yeah although if she was seeded
she's mentioned a lot and her thing is
hanging there's been a lot of hangings
this season but she's nowhere to be
found yet yeah it's interesting because
the Brotherhood are like we don't we
don't butcher people we're not like that
we hang them because it's a clean death
which is but you know it's caitlin's way
you're showing revenge because you know
she throat was cut and that's why she
prefers to hang people and also you know
they can suffer but she's not there I
genuinely thought when hound was gonna
take a piss in the river that he'd like
look up and she'd be behind him
apparently not but also it seems like
the Brotherhood are trying to take the
Hound north obviously where the real
fight is which means that he can't go
south and take part in Clegane ball so I
mean this is even before the clicking
ball gets wiped out you know fully
in yes but so our dreams were dashed
against the rocks twice killed you once
before Dondarrion happy to do it again
drop that arrow you bloody girl tougher
girls and you've tried to kill me so we
are back in the streets of marine things
were a lot more peaceful the red
priestess of preaching Danny's name
there's Targaryen banners everyone seems
happy yes but too happy it's a little
too quiet so typical throne style
spanner in the works the spanner being
you know the masses ships turning up but
before we see the Masters turn up we
actually say goodbye to Varys yeah
little bit suspicious timing I feel like
that guy knows too much I feel like he
must have known the Masters were gonna
completely retaliate because Tyrians
political you know political ideas as
he's got to Essos haven't repaid out and
Barris does disappear like 12 hours for
all kicks off or was it 12 minutes you
can't tell with this series but I kind
of thought it was gonna be a bit of a
Philistine when like the three advisors
start having their small boring party
where they don't know how to tell jokes
or finish them it's like a party with us
to be honest hey hey but then obviously
somebody kicks the door in and by that I
mean start shelling the pyramid there in
and destroying the city and here we
think oh this is marine garden then to
be honest I was quite annoyed because
Tyrion when he's in King's Landing when
he's the hand of the king he makes all
these great decisions and as soon as
yesterday sauce he just starts pissing
into the wind messes up and not only
that when he when the enemy is literally
at the gates literally banging on the
door he just goes oh yeah I made a
mistake I'm gonna make another one by
just suggesting this really bad military
strategy so I'm super glad but even
though we had that kind of
characterization with grey worm and he's
like telling jokes I'm really glad he
just stepped up and was like no yeah
this is what we're doing listen I know I
know fighting you might know wine but I
know how to kill a man but we don't
actually get that far because who jet
packs in fast travels from miles away De
Niro
and drag on yeah so I mean to be honest
next episode it's gonna be war she's got
to take the Dragons out from underneath
the pyramid she's gonna ride dro gone
into battle they're just gonna deal with
masters I think one or two things are
gonna happen she's going to use Row
going to torch the ships yeah or she
will use the khalasar to take the ships
yep for her own either way we're not
ships either way she's got some ships
and when the eyeline iron Islanders turn
up they're going to be like when the
hell's happening here we came all the
way we left the brothel early for this
yeah i mean because what's confusing is
if the masters had ships this whole time
why don't you just don't take them but
also if they're attacking and the
Ironborn you know finally get off their
asses and go me what else is asked get
over there in time to think oh this
person is attacking dinero's let's help
out and then she maybe she'll come with
us but you the jokes on them cuz she's
gonna go with him anyway someone's gonna
get boats all you gotta say someone else
alright then let's go to King's Landing
cuz to be honest this was part of my
favorite part of the episode just
because of the intrigue and stuff that
it was setting up yeah and the mortal
kombat fatality we'll talk about that in
a second and rust assured in the Edit
I'm putting the musical but so Cersei is
you know totally trapped in the red keep
and now the faith militant coming in and
just properly making demands of her but
of course she does not like that at all
so she uses a mountain to literally rip
a guy's head on ya head skull spine all
comes the whole thing which was just so
amazing and brutal but also you know she
goes to UM the Kings Hall and there's a
Royal Decree being made and here is
where another fan Theory just gets
completely dashed furthermore after much
prayer and reflection
the Crown has decided that from this day
forward trial by combat will be
forbidden throughout the Seven Kingdoms
does that mean no clicking ball I think
watching that episode both you and I
shrieked when those words came out of
his mouth you were like really is this
is this rest in peace Clegane Bowl ah I
mean to be honest it was too good to be
true but what they might be putting in
its place maybe even more awesome so sir
see you know she's kind of devastating
she's got the mountain who's gonna who
would be a clear winner oh for sure well
any trial by combat yeah unless it was
with a hand well that'll never happen
now but you know she's talking to Kai
burn and she says so just remember
something more Oh
magical we think the rumors are the
wildfire deposits that are gonna be
under the city and we know that hair and
lorises trial is gonna be in septic bail
or so I'm thinking she's gonna go full
bird man mad Queen this time Oh mad
Queen I mean I know she's not a
Targaryen but she's gone she's got
elements of the map yeah and she's gonna
Blood Center bail or Tommen's probably
gonna cop it no one will really care bah
Jaime will care Jamie comes back finds
out that she's done it and Maggie the
frogs prophecy you'll totally come true
because he's a little brother and he
realizes that she's insane it has to
kill us yeah that'll be all her three
kids dead Jamie's killed her so
basically we've lined up we've got rid
of one incredible founder and just swept
in another one in one out it's quite a
lot happened in Riverrun you see a BRI
Adam pod finally turn up see it's under
siege and they kind of like oh well this
is gonna go very well shantanu pods
amazing technical mine by the way was
like that looks like a siege yeah Thank
You captain obvious sabrine has to like
parlay with jamie she wants access to
the blackfish to try and convince him to
leave the keep go to San sir and Breanna
Jamie kind of have a touching moment
they kind of rekindle what made us love
them as a pair all those seasons ago and
she even tries to return his sword
oathkeeper yeah but no no bien she was
now you weren't it my favori thing
rather is the fact that because the
scene immediately preceding that is
Braun saying do you think they're gonna
you know so basically through the entire
scene everyone's decide like going
Arthur no no II didn't eventually they
do not Brienne enters Riverrun the
blackfish can not be convinced to lay
down his arms he admits that he can see
Kat in Sansa but that is not enough to
convince him to give up his ancestral
home I felt like that was a really
strange 180 because he is known for
being like a really stubborn guy like he
refuses to marry just for just for the
name just for the honor he's always been
really steadfast in his opinions so for
him to be like no no
never gave up the castle I won't even
bother reading this note from my niece
because I've never really met her and
then you know Brienne says one
incidental thing that goes oh okay yeah
sure I'll read it and then he keeps
saying like oh here she reminds me so
much of cat which again is another big
catalyst same drop out of nowhere but
and then yet ultimately nothing happens
he stays stubborn but he has that weird
like dip dip yeah you can see him kind
to think about it but then no and we
were all expecting after that to be to
see the siege but Jamie plays Edmure he
visits him in the prisoners tanks I'm
like a damn fiddle and Edmure just he
goes after Jamie's character basically
calls him super evil how do you live
with yourself and Jamie kind of says
well you know you got you got son how
about I launch him over the walls in a
catapult but that's the thing there
because I think especially sure watches
you get really caught up in Jamie's
Redemption arc because he was obviously
this really terrible human being and
then his relationship with brianne and
coming back from that um when he goes to
Dorne he's trying to do the right thing
but you remember some of the stuff that
he's done so I'm really glad that they
had that scene with Ed and Edna's just
like the square Joel your golden armor
tell me I want to know I trade here how
do you live with yourself because now
it's all I can think about as well I was
really proud of that me out during that
scene because he was saying what many of
us thought about Jamie but then he lets
all down by basically giving giving
river run to the Lannisters in the
phrase he approaches the gates orders
them to lay down their arms yeah and
police now they keep he's only been like
the lady that his wife that he does it
all for in the Sun he doesn't boy he's
never met a son and she got pregnant on
their wedding night which acc would be
the first time they slept together yeah
like that he hasn't seen it I've seen
them in years and he probably knew her
for about a week before they got married
like what you would you i mean i don't
think i would but the conclusion we see
is the blackfish escorts breandan pod to
escape you see the little touching wave
I hate it I hated that goodbye by the
way
because it was so pointless it's like
the Hulk walking away oh no no I mean I
mean blackfish and brannan pod because
he could have easily just got in the dam
but yeah he's like Jack in Titanic he
could have fit on the door well he
insists i'm having a sword fight he's
not had one in years and then just a
random Lannister tells Jamie he's dead
so do we are we holding on to the thing
where if they die off-screen do they die
for reals reals I think I've seen it i
think i think that part was to join is
quite badly done and i think he is dead
and that was not befitting of him i know
because he's such a let us see him go
out in a blaze of glory instead we just
get a throwaway line and forget about
the poor old black fish of course the
episode is called no one so he's
obviously centered around are you yeah
and it's the end of her story it's the
end of her but time in Braavos has come
to an end um so she's there the
beginning you know she's she's been
stabbed by the way she's been taking
care of my lady crane and again it's
this other kind of Catlin name-drop kind
of um you see Carolyn in lady crane
motherly figure that she's now like
looking after her she looks an awful lot
like Catlin obviously dies like Catlin
um but obviously the whole episode is
about Aria and her final culmination uh
into no one in to know on the final
confrontation with the wife and they
have this very bizarre like Assassin's
Creed esque run streets like this chase
um and for someone who just got stabbed
multiple times in the gut nacht I mean
the only reasoning that I can think of
that is maybe the milk of the poppy
hadn't worn off and that's the only
reason she could deal with the pain yeah
what led over that poor woman's oranges
yeah um my favorite was the shout out to
the woman who just went my basket
because we were wrong thank you um and
then she obviously leads the waste into
the room like you predicted last week
she leads her into them that was the
only part of the prediction that I got
right I'll admit to that cuts the candle
fights in the dark and we don't get to
see that death either which is quite
disappointing but we did get to see the
nollie after effect we get to see her
face with the eyes gouged out as well
in the Hall of faces and Jack and her
cars like well done you're finally no
one and I just goes a girl is a stark of
Winterfell and I'm going home so my
question do you Dave what was the point
in that well at the very least he gave
us some rad fighting abilities some real
dead of all sequences no you know what I
like it's one of those things what I
like it as I'm watching it and when I
think back to it I'm like that was a
season you wasted man just yeah I mean I
want more for that character so I would
have loved it if she'd you know kept
with the house of black and white and
then ended up going back to Westeros as
a part of them and then having that kind
of connection rather than just
squandering her relationship with them
hopefully all the stuff she's done over
the last season all the training she's
gone through will play a bigger part of
carrots in the future and make the
payoff a little grander than just the
seer back off West I mean I am in Justin
to see where she ends up if she ends up
in the south she still I got the list to
work through yeah true she ends up in
the North could be nice I'll stark
family reunion maybe all their hatred
and bad times hey how's it going but
also maybe she'll find Nymeria cuz she's
just running around the Riverlands right
true and also that's where the Hound is
so maybe she'll be reintroduced to two
homes oh and that'd be nice a couple of
contenders for death of the week I felt
one clear contender though I think let's
talk about the Bronco with our banners
because a couple of then we get some
axes in the face the debate of how much
the Hound is going to maim them I think
made that scene that was pretty great
and also the way that the Hound was like
you are terrible at dying Heather's
really last words [ __ ] you come on you
can do it but I think obviously the
clear winner the mortal kombat fatality
fatality so as per usual we are going to
talk a little bit about next episode so
if you don't want that spoiled for you
chew off now but thank you for watching
but those of you who do want to hear
about it next episode episode 9 the one
where it all happens battle of the
bastards this looks like the most
focused episode I've ever seen in the
teaser it is literally all by other
bastards is this gonna be like oh all
the time like an hour long fight god I
hope so I hope so i really hope they're
gonna go full hard home with it you know
just really i mean it's the same
directing with the guy who directed
heart home there gonna be some really
intense battle sequences um i also hope
we get to see more of john's slightly
different character now that he's been
resurrected yeah because you know it
resurrection does change people and he
does say if i die don't bring me back
again don't bring me back but i'm also
hoping that little finger basically i
wanted to go full Helm's Deep I want it
to look like they're gonna leave you get
a reference low the rings of this I
always have to and little fingers gonna
be the Gandalf and you know look to the
east it's gonna be little finger the
ninth of the veil to come save them at
the last minute I hope I'm the scene I
think we're gonna see some character
development is it looks like Davos finds
sheron's pyre I think you're right but I
also think judging from what you see of
Davos in the next episode preview he
looks like a man who has nothing to lose
so I'm genuinely afraid that they're
gonna kill him off but he'll go out in a
blaze of glory because you know he's
done everything and basically being with
Stannis sort of it was like the purpose
of his life and shereen that friendship
that they had his it's the last element
of Stannis that he can really hold on to
and then he discovers that she died in
such an awful way and no one told him
especially not Melisandre so I'm
wondering if her his loyalty to her is
gonna his loyalty I should say I mean
they're just there for convenient yeah
it's gonna be completely shattered well
at least if he does get killed off and I
cry I can blame
the onions thank you for holding that
pose as hello so overall David what did
you think of episode 8 that was an
intense episode I was kind of skeptical
thinking they might stretch a few pieces
because obviously this is one of the
longer episodes but Dave they nailed it
they got a lot of really intense things
in there crush them my dreams but also
ignited some some new ones yeah I'm
night I mean some of the parts I'm not a
hundred percent happy about I'm not
completely convinced for ayahs story arc
and I think the blackfish was a bit
underused but overall i'm still super
excited about the stuff that's eating
with Cersei because that girl she's she
gonna get it do it she's gotta go home
so you know two episodes left and they
are gonna be the longest in season
seasons past so I'm very excited so
don't forget more gamespot of Thrones
next Monday and it's gonna be episode 9
see you know it's gonna be a good one
Dave why can people find you you can
find me on Twitter at a regular dave i'm
on twitter at Lucy James games if you
like to listen to the audio version of
this be sure to find us on iTunes please
rate please subscribe because we love
doing this show who really do but for
more we'll see you next week
you